well sir fool was so full podcast
welcome everybody to the what so full
podcast we're at it again back up to the
were so full Park has a backup
no we're back underwater full podcast we
got about the realtor is right here
Brando Wheels of Steel Yemen Iran I went
into the improv this weekend bro after
three we got back from totally dog
Sunday sleepy as hell bro I want to be
rescued that night I was laid out a
little cushion you guys went to the
improv in it yeah Oh Rebecca Cory show
yeah well Lisa right here looking hot
looking at he just came up doing that
movie deuce Bigalow that deuce Bigalow
that will Marky Mark the fighter I'm
gonna do poor bro Oh Boogie Nights
boogie dice I am like you my hair like
roller girl is she looking like ron
jeremy
9070 when he was dead you better get a
mirror dawg I don't know Roger me now SS
that part nah it looks cheap bro I heard
that's all I read about this book be
cheap hurdies Gilbert Godfried cheap
surreal life
yes lawn chairs at his house does it
down there has velcro shoes like that
one time we seen him with sweats all the
time did you were you a smooth operator
I took off you and Vinny and I haven't
seen him that's when he said he'd look
like Vinny's dad look like a big-ass
sheriff see Rosie all right as soon as
we said we're gonna sneak in he bowled
out that's how you do it I guess I think
yeah hop the fence everybody look that I
damn well how come I didn't jump too
late doc and
you were to jump gate stage by well we
had to just go see like if the
securities this way this way and then a
little troupe took off in a golf course
Dolf Cartman just took off and went over
I see you would over that game was the
first thing you did just walk toward the
stage act normal like I was there
already
let's see a social jack hell no and then
we seen cake that night
who else we've seen a couple other bands
do but it was San Diego Street scene yes
oh I want to go stand up for pizza with
Rebecca Cory over the shore with Chris
D'Elia where he took off and the girl
from The Big Bang Theory hosted the
blonde one
kaley cuoco there's a lady hotel Lily
Tomlin and it wasn't really Tomlin was
assisted oh it was a bad lady or their
old lady from Austin Powers what oh they
look the same though the wife right yeah
I told Lily Talia the buoy - yeah her
name was Mindy sterling Mindy sterling
spirit of IMDb you know who's alive but
that was dead who Bob Bob which about is
about of the real mom Ross said they
started toward another actress the
actress yeah yeah well she died of need
your help for the baby
never cancer as a result of cirrhosis
she was a drunk I use that term drunk
they're always drink you bro a little
bit yeah it was it was [ __ ] chronic
cirrhosis and then liver cancer I guess
sure that last show I saw a very Dora
yeah no not so it was just I married
Dora yeah I love that show
it was a great show she was also she was
in Jacob's Ladder remember Jacob's
Ladder
with Tim Robbins no Tim Robbins yeah he
has
Tim Robbins has like hallucinations of
demons around the city like you know on
the subway and all the stuff helping out
scary movie yeah like maybe 90 something
like that out 93 yeah but so peace lady
those those like a rush out there was
also a what you call it a meeting greed
red carpet and now though the two pit
bulls that we had here were there Todd
and Sally and there being a pizza to
have a slice hole now we did have a box
home type of guy good that was a good
tomato pie right yeah I thought my show
go well but were a little too my set the
next day it was all right that was good
it the people were not really comedy fan
people they were there for the
fundraiser you know these are fundraiser
artsy fartsy types there were few people
who got it who were like with the comedy
thing they like the magician he followed
some magician whoa and they like you
know these jokes rocked in Toledo the
Veil the veil of America yeah what
happened brother in the Mid America is
now West Coast or what people get up and
people get sensitive in the West Coast
now if there is a West Coast of new
Midwest or what the West Coast a new
Bible Belt and to give people get really
shuddered over to do my jobs down over
here
well everybody wants to act like
everything's perfect full and it's not
life isn't peachy Doug
- rallies bro the harder they come for I
want for our lessons but you're making a
dog eating jokes
I said no I opened no this was a dog
show fundraiser and I opened up with a
joke like yeah bad I don't know I never
owned a dog but I've been called a dog
hey you guys sell it out
yo solo hell yeah dude stand up for
Pitt's do how's Rebecca Cory doing
she was good bro she were riding around
all frantic you know like where's
everybody
Whitney Cummings canceled because her
house was on fire
do those fires ain't no joke I'm lying
in row but she had to take all her
animals out she had horses so our horses
are gone
she took about brought all the horses
that saved that they got rescued from
Malibu gets where they're at
we're on the beach brought enough sand
chillin it looks like it looks at the
whole center stage Wow the movie first
came here was paid you know just a bunch
of horses on the beach just right down
the shore Zuma Beach Zuma Beach you
can't drink the water though can they
yeah no but it was just like we've been
coming to clear her house then it's
famous actress Tara payment I never
heard of her house got burned out and my
acting coach she told me about that our
friend of hers play Peter Peter hit
house that burned to shreds
she was shortly followed yeah that's
hitting nothing but rubble now should be
like Kanye West and those people did
they hire private firefighters to save
their homes
Wow there's such a thing yes I be a mad
bankroll dog called resources homie
so did that part of the valuable Police
Department
there's a picture going around about the
migrant workers working the migrant
fields and there's fires behind them
yeah I seen in George Lopez's place I
don't give a [ __ ] Mexicans astray
soldiers talk out here feeders like
soldiers making sure we get fed huh I
mean you can see that [ __ ] right over
the San Joaquin Valley right there do
the spices I said well over there is
surely we're safe yeah they got a work
done if not you know mr. day I don't
know highly also the beasts are so
majestic live like Old Spice commercial
it does bro look it up horses in Malibu
up Whitney Cummings
she also got she took care a lot our
rescue us bro before Hannah right now
afterwards yeah she was offering like
trailer she had people with trailers and
stuff ready to evacuate help evacuate
that Malibu lines place and they have
like a safari and kind of like sanctuary
there next to it and also a friend of
mine are based on Instagram they were
Sophia Rory yeah yeah the the vine stars
the other vine stars but but now Sophie
said a broken broken SP bolsa she had
she had her own her own being a page
dude she went out there with a bunch of
foods and trucks and tried to put it go
to the cars
Rabbids pigs laughs to goats energy to
go to their car damn you don't know if
we're gonna eat the backseat I'll just
trippin on how many people died it's up
to 50 right
I heard the whole child of Paradise got
burned out right paradise California
yeah man I can't fire and then yeah
paradise [ __ ] [ __ ] escobar
posted a photo of his house at least 200
miles away at the he go to see the smoke
smoke
isn't that one big fat bow huh what sir
fool Joe Rogan had to leave bro I had to
evacuate yeah go to that ice chamber bro
and just go up come on all frozen it go
now they were feeding firefighters dude
hell yeah bro bison but you know a
serious Brooklyn I've never been to Joe
Rogan's house but I been to stop segura
house
Bert Kreischer and man you could like
that tower with water management so try
to the ghettos never been so safe they
get holy say it bro I think we're about
roaches bro a roaches going to tell your
nose dude a roach will survive a nuclear
blast
put it down no just leave before that
fire bro they know what's up roaches are
dumb dog people thinking about man
animal life being killed
you know what analyze life or being
killed there was there were cages the
ones that were locked up and what father
took off are these sanctuaries suppose
we didn't know Paul Mooney said if you
got four legs you can't get away that's
on you they're hungry dude look at dude
like they're on their last leg if
they're hungry ready to die what are
they gonna do fool what are they gonna
do the ritual take a cat that don't rip
a cat apart dog yeah ain't no joke done
fire then like what revelations isn't
like fire and all that [ __ ] to do for
what come on man that [ __ ] is serious to
eat it bro yeah man look you know how do
you like Toledo's cool waffle toledo was
cool bad i were doing the show and
the second shows packed the first show
we had a good show I met some cool
people then the second show bad so
[ __ ] juggernaut [ __ ] right up
on stage you there now he was drunk as
[ __ ] I was eating when that fool did
that cuz I always see when you're on
stage though huh I would not do that
salad good good
Jerry good that coffin over the hotel
hell no you had to take off and go to
the show yeah and uh yeah dude but the
dude was drunk didn't he came from he
actually was there at the first show in
the back and then they bought tickets
again but the dude was like drunk drunk
but it's funny like from what I heard
the guy grabbed him and put him in a
hole but right when he got on stage he
got all like you know he got all he got
all silent I got scared bro all the
lights you nobody knows that what so
fool for real dude like this dude what
up man what's up man
what about word Toledo as we get this
funny boat and these drunk ass people
were like heckling from the back of the
show boy Detroit you know our best
friends are they will represent Detroit
that's all right stay right there yeah
yeah you know or how do you call it ha
ha they bought tickets for a [ __ ]
second show just can't get enough gonna
get enough heckling hey dudes anybody
singing for the second Shore they bite
they stand up front so now they're on
the side of me like this they're talking
they're talking they're talking I was
annoying up there talking over here to
whatever but there's no the girl boy for
Joseph stages it rose that me why yeah
and like I could have been like afro
band and just [ __ ] him I love you know
I still have 35 more minutes to go you
know you have before the show so I just
couldn't buy Karate Kid stand at your
side beat the crane the great big that
crane you should have swept the lake
really a create more like the forklift
now we're gonna kick him slowly and then
push them away so slow-mo drop the
Shantanu the manager Ricky he's half
German and half are Mexican either we
just beat her schnitzel ha ha ha shows
up bad if you get some in a full nelson
bro is in the food
I don't know was a UFC move cuz all into
that [ __ ] so you know about your seniors
already to practice that [ __ ]
so their food was like he got up he was
doing school a school where haha they go
outside to give a little lecture you
[ __ ] him selfie I'm [ __ ] up for that
last time sorry I messed with your head
he got to do with us is here he's
Detroit fighters so they kicked out who
out dog and they gave him the boot
though he was all sad but they're now
they keep the fools out they pay their
bill they must have been like 500 bucks
of the whole liner stakes for the bugs
to shows yeah a drinking order 50 bucks
of alcohol
there's teen at the sea hotel we are oh
man same floor lobby waited for an
autograph work a t-shirt that [ __ ]
brother he grabbed each other grabbed me
and said give me the bike I want to say
something funny
what did he want proposed dog good on
your time yeah but what's he got up
there bro him he looked at the audience
and he froze he got shot the lights hit
his eyes to rope a little bit of
squirtle shake him out he stayed his Joe
Jones bro
he got scared they took him out and
whatever but then this fool stayed there
at 3 3 o'clock in the morning the cops
showed up to the hotel room the last
night on Saturday night no the same way
the
no those one of those people do to a
couple brothers dude in a couple like
white-trash chicks you know a couple
white trash gee sounds like Ohio we were
in Perrysburg right there which is right
outside of Toledo but uh it was like
Tweaker chicks do that like tattoos on
their thighs you without dude I was
watching it from the little little I
hope I hope watching all the action dude
kept on going I said and I had a cut a
big-ass bar so I just open the door
closed that [ __ ] anybody can see it's
everything stopped and it was commotion
there was two hotel rooms two doors down
on the left and on the right and just do
people partying and I think they owed
somebody money dude the cops security
guard came that one do they look like he
called the cops and the two cops grabbed
those two brothers put him in cuffs and
they took a chick to him
yeah to the Tweaker stayed and then
after that no no he's done tweaking all
the way to LA that's crazy
oh hi Oh going down was it a hotel it
was a garden in Hilton do drivers said
that's where Jerry Seinfeld stays nicest
hotel me everywhere used to be bad but
that was good
you know oh yeah little cooler set but
it's been there ten years but if you
walk on to the area Elaine's a lot of
fine stores like a lot businesses Josh a
man you walk out the store there's a god
Waffle House Waffle House and it is a
Chinese restaurant and they like they
save it all the bakery but they do yeah
it's our friends they don't let our
secrets out on but pure dad's pocket
change those bombers doodles in a while
dude it was good but I give you what if
you're like chicken beak or chicken feed
they have their chicken feet out dog
feet crazy ass Chinese Filipino food
I've seen a video man somebody took a
video of the all the folks in not all
the folks but you know they're little
farmers market and there's dogs out
there
filming it like real no it's brutalized
it's crazy bananas that's right oh I
don't see the difference don't get Nick
started on the healthy stuff this guy's
not a captain plant-based now oh yeah my
wife's being gay but then she made me up
she's sure they're being a little rubber
that [ __ ] jacket a box of cheese taco
hell yeah but what's so cool because the
bacon boys right here but reducible deal
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
Fabulous Baker boys radio legends liver
started all over the world hip-hop
station power 106 I know you guys get on
there there but you guys were
responsible for it let it be known
responsible for the hip-hop radio format
yeah discovered Tito I made this yeah
Tito used to come to the show everyday
and one day I just hop let's tell him on
you know we just had we used to have
conversations with them off the air and
we thought it was fun and funny so we
just like you know let's tow him on
let's go Tito on and he became a monster
on his own man so when he would do
things or say I taught him all the lingo
so we had him saying hood rat and this
and that
Westside you know all these things these
nuts all that we taught Tito all that
stuff and he took it and ran with it
like crazy so he has a great personality
he's very genuine family orientated
oriented excuse me orientated I was like
so yeah he had a great personality and
just like a grandfather he's like uncle
everybody's uncle right yeah everybody
has an uncle like Tito so that's what it
was yeah so it was fun it was we had a
lot of time we still talk to him we
still talk to him we keep in touch with
him we're actually doing a new show now
on on - you can hear us every morning
and we're trying to get him to come in
to do some bits and stuff with us you
know we want to do some lists and Tito's
got a bunch of ideas for Tito but it's
really up to him in his schedule when he
can make it you know
he's retired so he's very busy
[Laughter]
yes we're born and raised that's right
right man whatever man but you got one
out here at the power 106 in the
beginning like this is 1997
you know 1985 mmm and my first my first
real comedy game was a Bakersfield man
at a pool house over a bunch of brothers
you know and now they had a comedy show
just for that Sunday night they gave me
$50 yeah and it's not the only Mexican
there yes you got $50 and a pass out of
Bakersfield yeah the only reference to
another Mexican with you guys humble
beginning telling to wait to get your
money
you did something that's dangerous
they might rob you after they give you
the money boom you want the worst gig
ever did in Bakersfield like covering up
the Gold Room we learned from this I'm
probably one of the gigs that we created
ourselves like the New Year's Eve gig
that nobody came to that was horrible
bro we make a boys so we invited alt to
come down pay him to come down we rented
out a big ol Hall tour in Bakersfield in
Bakersfield the Kern County Fair
they had auditoriums and halls and stuff
and we were throwing gigs successfully
and then we try to do this one gig pass
out did the same thing pass out flyers
I don't know if we got I think our
girlfriends were there mom was there
Hilti came nobody nobody really cares
yeah
just bad so yeah we threw her own worst
gig homeboy super former one who I think
he did he probably did yeah yeah
actually um he came on he gave us our
name the Baker voice yeah really yeah so
a guy goes recipes Jay Thomas appreciate
that Mucha Alex that's a beginner right
yeah boom dog donkey dong yeah boomer
was there yeah we're talking about that
the other day who was talking about Jeff
Jeff Garcia was talking there a huge
boom we used to have a joint that
prophecies like this big Christmas party
I really will read you have like the
Cobbers the gift of laughter everybody
brings the gifts we first checks but
well Gio and I were thinking about
getting a bucket who should somebody
might steal the idea ya know what it is
I do a voice in it's pretty much taken
from Emilio Rivera's voice but to get a
little puppet like a ventriloquist
puppet yeah call it little puppy got you
a home yeah he's going what do you cry
no would one day is hurting you
not even try to get somebody hi Taylor a
little penalty yeah cuz I've been I've
been shopping for him but I'll get the
plastic one and someone the [ __ ]
wanted right two thousand bucks for this
cool one about like can I get this fool
like see him at night see would
movements are let's steal that moment
right yeah her to dog but I mean just
get a good little one a little chilly
turret they've gotta get one of those
little puppet makers from the Jim Henson
or something like that yeah that'll be
another thing to be a [ __ ] lay
nevertheless yeah but that's the idea do
you know forty hours to the [ __ ] is a
penalty gonna be a respectful public
yeah boy is just something for the hood
though they saw the for the quarter sack
bro when you get heard you do a job you
just a character that was the funny
thing this your birthday man
I thought y'all were Mexican yeah when
we first got to LA every thought we were
black because we were speaking hip-hop
lingo saying dope this that right all
the stuff we were saying but they
thought we were black I would say on
Fridays you guys were always tuned out
with Will Venable event though right on
the morning time yeah yeah in the
morning time but but we still do a night
show called Friday night flavors as well
that's actually how we got our start Oh
Friday night flavors was an underground
hip-hop show okay so that was kind of
the the whole idea of you know the
hip-hop the music taking it and
expanding it throughout the whole
station but that was like the beginning
the Friday night flavors at the
beginning of the hip-hop
format for power Genesis and Jenna that
was the that was the hub right there the
first time I you guys have the first any
rule with biggie right out in LA right
yeah happy yeah the firt before even bad
boy came out bad boy it just came out
hearted right just started I actually
got a phone call from a friend of ours
Adrian Miller and he said hey I got puff
in town he's got a brand new label
called bad boy he's got an artist called
notorious b.i.g he wants to bring him up
and so we were like yeah bring him up
and you know before all that a little
bit after that all the west coast East
Coast beef start right cuz Brad that was
right before ready to die right yeah
yeah yeah yeah they had just dropped by
party and [ __ ] so yeah that was his
first single from a
was a Muslim track right before that was
that a flavor in your bike Craig man
that was a first one well that was hit
that was the big hit for a bad boy
yeah and Craig Mack was like the the
head I guess the the biggest heart is on
bad boy at that point in time and biggie
was pretty much unknown and he was just
hanging out we were interviewing a Craig
mag and Biggie was just hanging out on
the side and they told me he's got it
records too so he's like Oh biggie you
got records - he's like yeah yeah but
Craig Mack was the interview that was
the main interview yeah yeah we were the
definitely the first ones to interview
him out here we helped break a lot of
Bad Boy Records out here you know from
biggie to to the Craig Mack's to the
112's and all the other stuff yeah one
my one 12 CD black yeah how did you guys
move from Bakersfield to Los Angeles
Baker for somewhere else for there to LA
no Baker show to Los Angeles uh we got a
military man Jay Thomas yeah so we used
to come to LA a lot to produce music we
were working with mellow man ace and kid
frost and all the Latin rappers and n
knows shouts out to Tony G and Julio G
those guys really hooked us up with you
know working with those guys in that
whole realm the whole Latin rapper
moment alt all those guys we were
working with them so one time we're
learning that though oh yeah the dr. Dre
sampler yep yeah one time when we were
here in LA our cancelar our studio
session got cancelled so we were like
you know what are we gonna do we ended
up going to a record label called
profile records and it's guy named Bruce
Rider worked there and so he long story
short he was like hey what are you guys
doing we're like nothing our studio got
cancelled he said you want to go to
dinner so at dinner we didn't know who
was all gonna be there Dave Morales who
did mid days that power was there and
Harold Austin who was the music director
for 92.3 the beat who just came from the
Bay Area so we literally sitting there
at Antonio's on Melrose and we have
power 106 at the table and 92.3 at the
table and Nick V does the story go ahead
oh yeah the story we're drinking we're
la Bamba we're having a good old time
right doing the damn thing and I'm like
boom slam my hand on the table and like
Morales by this time this year next year
this year by this time next year we're
gonna be working at power 106 and
everybody started laughing it was a huge
joke it was a great moment right there
right but that was you know foreseen and
foreshadowing what would really happen
so by that time next year I think it was
maybe three or four months after day
yeah we got a job 106 yeah damn
so Morales hit us up outside he's like
man it's like you may think I'm drunk
and I am but he's like you guys would be
perfect we're trying to start a new
hip-hop show we need some hip-hop host
you guys are living the lifestyle you
were in the studio with yo yo House of
Pain hooligans you doing some remixes
for Cypress Hill and all that stuff at
the edits at its height right there so
he's like you guys would be perfect for
this you guys also DJ's wrote and
producer was a pistol grip pump on my
lap at all times yeah which was also of
the last record the rage put out they
did a cover to cover yeah yeah man yep
mr. grandpa you can love so our row
blows while driving
I used to who's giving you that
information he's using information and
stories now but yeah all that [ __ ] is he
still plays mad I still play my don't
roll blunts anymore we're driving I mean
smoking up
I met you guys before when I was a Tory
one get rid lesser than I am that's
right that's right so you were playing
Madden with this
you had short hair starting started
Miami was a lot of fun we got a chance
to hang out with a lot of comedians what
we're Dasher Wilson never came in
together everybody likes uncle Luke no
man he's our big time he's a retired now
but he was there for the championship
when Shaq was there oh the basketball
player
yeah oh not your Johnson now he's a
beloved guy from Miami Heat damn anyway
no he forgot Bob Johnson Alonzo Mourning
Alonzo Mourning yeah yeah yeah that'd be
yeah Alonzo Mourning yeah everywhere you
go you got make the neighborhood yours
huh yeah I have to cuz in Miami like the
other like when I saw you guys in Miami
we're promoting the Miami in problem
Gabriel glasses and we're playing matter
with you guys oh so cool sure it was
cool yeah you got a lot of love like you
were happy to see some type of
California there yeah for sure yeah but
you have made me your words like it's
like is it like if I like you can always
pour there but you were not always there
like even I love the morning showed up
you remember you guys he loved you guys
you we have to especially we go into a
new marketplace you know we're brand new
so we have to absorb every word oh yeah
some people are scared because we
weren't we're not escape we're not as
scared we're down to move across the
country homes that big buy what I gotta
do I gotta feed my family tell em that
yeah we're we're down to move in and go
into the city and absorb it and become
part of it and and once they accept us
then you know then we can do us you know
we can really be who we are and we're
this is a family business 30 years
running here so why not
yeah you guys ever I'm I'm from the
Midwest so I don't need to know I didn't
grow up with you guys but that was a
purse bro yeah yeah sure all the funk
yeah but because so you guys did you
ever go into syndication or you did you
always just move around to market we
have a syndicated mix show that's been
goin almost 8 18 years it's been going
almost 18 years so we're on like over 50
stations around the country no no no
that one's on terrestrial radio so
you'll hear us in Kansas City Paris and
Biloxi you'll hear us all over the place
in different cities around the country
we just actually picked up another
couple stations in Africa so we have
some stuff internationally as well but
that's a that's a mixture so it's all
music in tents it's very short talk
breaks it's not like what we're doing
now we're doing an actual morning show
now so we're getting to kind of show our
personality a little bit you know have
fun and joke around with what's going on
in the world today you know stuff like
that
light-hearted stuff the UFOs CIA
Facebook thank you like my mom you guys
were the big big you it was crazy that
was before we're from the same
neighborhood that father great boy at my
yeah yeah so everybody do you get were
did you get this juice so it's not for
choice oh yeah so about Thomas Paine is
like it's bad like in LA like me go over
there
make it boy gonna give our toys yeah I
get it
yeah yeah that was me when you give away
computers to nobody viewing for
computers that all the toys were stolen
one Christmas I think he was a yes it
was at the fire station all the toys
they were just jacked and we pulled
together the community and we stopped
and we said we want to replace these
toys so we asked
come together and we got a truckload of
toys it took it down to the neighborhood
and gave it out actually we stole the
toys and give them back which is out now
hijack the toys a restaurant ever press
you guys to play this album no he never
pressed this we only met you I think
once right it was once at the Interscope
office yeah that was the ones formal
meeting which should but should told us
to stop playing his records yeah yeah no
we were the first people to play Snoop
Dogg's first single and that we got a
cease and desist from his lawyer and
records like no the first single woman
got on death row why did it why did they
want you because it wasn't supposed to
be released well they didn't have a
title yet actually the name of the song
it was who I am I ever and it became
what's my name
so you tell great things we guys get a
copy of it
so Dorjee he's not even a record
business anymore Kevin bean a friend of
a friend of ours that worked in the
business had had a copy of it and he
helped us he gave us a lot of stuff so
early on we got like the brat So So Def
Jermaine Dupri all that stuff like we
broke funk-defied we broke warren g
regulate these guys used to come play
video games in our house so we used to
have at it we said yeah Matt and Madden
exactly so we used to leave for work at
5:00 in the morning to go to the morning
show and at our house would be Snoop
Dogg freaking born the twins
Warren G all those guys and we're like
yo we got to go just lock the door we
just yeah and we take off and they just
stay there and we come back to be gone
so
yeah yeah man that's my name on Madden
on PlayStation 4 you wouldn't come at me
that's real for real
yeah what's awful you only do plays this
before yeah okay
I suck well you know what man try it man
get out be what team to use the Raiders
with golf as a quarterback okay and I
have very standard oh so you play mutt
then yeah man ultimate team okay team
okay
I would like to another way you can play
also right mm-hmm the one and you can
ask a friend yeah no I don't never do it
uh when I had what the first Nintendo
was cool or stories but doesn't that go
[ __ ] shoot BB guns right bike yeah
mom okay deal of the house - bro - I
love my nephew daddy broke my little
brother had the Nintendo and he's you go
like get stuck into one corner and have
78,000 Coral
what's up fool okay man real quick like
this week I'll be a Buffalo New York man
I'm gonna be freezing my ass off but
I'll come there cow this Friday through
Sunday helium comedy club helium Tempe
Arizona December 7th through the 9th
Tempe improv on general California
Ontario improv December 27 through 30th
and that's all I think I almost sold out
Friday and Saturday yeah or Thursday and
Sunday we added a Thursday show all sold
out
Denver Colorado December 31st I will be
there chillin the Paramount Theater as
always get those tickets fast also bad
you been asking yes I'm gonna be in a
Turlock California generate 1926 26
together going fast
you're gonna be in Bridgeport
Connecticut in January to the first week
at stress factory oh goodie brand a lot
of cold places the orders crazy for that
Club I don't know from the Jersey motive
the comedian also but he doesn't love he
does everything he ran for Congress to
read for cargo Wow
and he [ __ ] out just he does
corporate gigs to like look over he
bears birthday parties my rich size but
he so pumped up you know madly pumped
does he see that the short pack
ah you know what he goes back onstage
bag does his time he promotes everything
yeah everything did try the veal the
best in the city he's a man of the city
before the jaleco the big boss man would
it would spaghetti with a kid with a
bunch of me boss good now who's getting
fancy bro they give me one meatball one
big fat one what do big [ __ ] fat
meatball bro you ain't a [ __ ]
hamburger you watch a little one yeah
you want to experience it over and over
again
I want like you know six big ones yeah
I'll take the regularly I want the big
one this is Italian guy in Las Vegas it
looks good though but here's one big
bebop it a little softball Wow big one
then you open it up so you look at your
real bad you just use a heavily read of
ground beef because you're gonna try to
break it up with your knife work yeah so
you get snap it's not you can't do it oh
no oh not me no here no I don't think
I'm ever gonna go vegan plant-based yeah
beets I can do oats I could do berries
fruits and so there's so much how long
you been doing that for not seriously
weeks two hours no after after lunch
yeah yeah absolutely your digestive
system works a lot better see this the
problem with him that I have with him
okay because he's doing all this healthy
stuff okay can I have a cigarette but
then he'll smoke a cigarette or a joint
I've just you know or drink he'll drink
and get drunk and then he'll smoke and
then he'll go on plan base which is
gracias Ino state plan base here's the
deal when you're eating all this dead
food whether it's fried french fries
fried chicken it's basically dead
there's no nutrition in there but if
you're eating stuff that comes from the
ground or from the earth or from the
trees it's alive it literally absorbs
energy and you transform that into you
so when we're putting all this other
food in us that really doesn't have any
energy for its nutritional value then
how are we gonna feel as machines you
know so that's about two weeks now and
look at me now and look at the
difference now I've already inviting you
yes I try it why don't you get with the
challenge man I was challenging you he's
been vegan for seven years so do you
like it yeah something happened
health-wise yeah he was dieting poorly
and like he was just like see you know
yo-yo now I mean he's still he's a
snacker though
so you know we try to balance it up but
when he's on the road it's cookies Taco
Bell because they can't find a TV in the
country notice there's nothing healthy
late at night you can't go through a
good drive-through with healthy food
ever foods and buy stuff to make you
know if you should actually do a vegan
restaurant on a 24 hour vegan taco spot
yeah as far as the presents there's some
good that's on Woodman and Saticoy what
man is Saticoy I wanna eat some vegan
Velia and vegan carnitas be here now
tortas I usually like Vito's mega Tino's
yeah Tito's they are flock to they have
delicious fun really good that's so good
there's a big did something happen with
you or anything I just want to change
your lifestyle as far as your diet I
don't I don't you know what I just
gaining knowledge about the animals and
how they're treated and how they are
killed and murdered and basically all
those hormones go into them before
they're dead and then we turn around and
we cook it and we eat those hormones so
that turns around and makes us scared
and upset as far as our our digestive
system is and our gut is really where a
lot of our energy and everything comes
from and people don't realize that
that's really the center of all of our
energy and the things we push forward in
our life on a day-to-day so got to pay
attention to it and be nice to it
because it'll be nice to you sometimes
people don't are nice to it and guess
what it hurts and you got to go to the
doctor and you're plugged up and all
this stuff and you're crying and you're
hurting and but it's really based upon
your diet and what you're putting inside
yourself so we're really capable of
keeping ourselves healthy or hurting
ourselves with everything that we put in
our mouths whether it's cigarettes or
water or fruit or alcohol
alcohol that [ __ ] yeah their owners are
Mexican one is from Mexico and brought
his family recipes just veganized
somebody said hot cheetos it's it's
authentic flavors and everything just
know me there goes my global culture
there priest man I thought about that a
little while ago so I got the part I got
my name changed to global consciousness
kind of like the basketball player was
his name which Metta World Peace Metta
World Peace Metta World Peace god bless
ya everybody's got an opportunity to
change Muhammad Ali [ __ ] character call
of goo it might be what I just wanted to
add tour date but I wanted to announce
or asked if people wanted to donate to
your brother in Mexico not donate money
don't give him money no he doesn't need
money give him you know old coat that's
gently used you know store DJ's like
shirts
he's a 2x and I'm 40 20 40 - 30 pants
he's got that torso like you the long
torso
42:30 pants and so if you have any old
jeans or any of that send them to p.o
box 8 0 to 7 Mission Hills California 9
1 3 4 5 that's Felipe's world so send it
there and we'll by the 30th of November
and we'll ship it down to him in Mexico
a lot like toothbrushes at eBay yeah all
that stuff of course yeah
yeah yeah I'll give them be shoe then
their shoes no but my brother look that
makes it go so yeah me buddy give it to
other people
he's day with take the good [ __ ] I got
some old boxer now we don't want those
that were so cool so yeah with you up
early usually we're on from 93 to 99 you
know in alternative yeah not long but I
forgot I think you could have been
longer you know there were some things
that happened and but it is what it is
so we just continue to move we you know
we're luckily lucky enough to start our
syndicated mixture in 2001 and it's been
going for that long and now we're
looking back getting to the Monday
through Friday syndication so that's why
we created a brand-new show that we're
working on now that's Miami or somewhere
else after after LA we went to San
Francisco for a year and then from South
Shore yeah yeah before well Chuy was
there when we were there as well yeah
kami okay and then we went to then we
went to Miami I took a couple years off
then we went to Miami in 2003 we were
there from like 2003 to 2006 and then we
went to San Diego briefly for a second
and then we've been you know back in LA
I've been back in know like since 2008
so yeah I'm in hiding now in homes
that's why the big boy Sammy did
anything I've been in the slammer for a
little bit no TV shows we did a pilot we
did a pilot we did some guest guest
appearances Jamie Jamie Foxx we did
homeboys from outer space yes we didn't
do Wayans brothers but we ought to play
yourselves right yeah and then New York
Undercover we did that as well I got the
hook
I get the best of me yeah so we're
trying to get written into the new
Friday coming up - we're gonna have DJ
pool on next week next week I have a
song right here or something man turn to
make a voice oh we did a porn no we did
we hosted it something on Playboy though
he be there anybody TV that was
desperate row out of our character
really I don't like bonus it's its
chicks they're in their lingerie or
whatever and we're like hanging out what
do you do what are we doing there yeah
yeah it's cool but it's not really that
yeah looking back on it just shouldn't
have done it
I mean felt I don't know it looked like
I don't try to sing that [ __ ] wait a
minute though did you catch the chat
money exact scene right here
yeah we're not working that part one of
six men started working there at the
heart you know of crack man you guys
hear a lot of food go down huh yeah
crack cocaine yeah no not not really
nothing when we were that talented crack
and then chronic came like ah the
chronic area will be the crack age was
back in Bakersfield for us 84 9 yeah
yeah hit everybody hit everybody pretty
bad out there first 9 I don't know I was
too young they wouldn't let me in at the
house that was deejaying though at 84 so
they kept me out of the crack game the
turntables Lee and both DJ yeah yeah
yeah house party this [ __ ] oh yeah of
course house party try to that's right
that's what we turn to DJ because it
couldn't break this I tried yeah we
could try to rap 200
I did I did something a couple I still
do like little intros for our Baker boy
show like little Baker boys raps and
stuff but in 1992 we did it alcohol and
drug-free commercial I got paid 750
dollars 1992 like I said I wrote the rap
we came up to Los Angeles tove up here
and I minivan dropped it did a video
there's a video I can show you guys oh
that's gonna be on the Documenta to be
on the documentary bit
various 92 shot foot it lives in check
it out kick it into Baker boys lint
alcohol the drug free shot so anybody
from Bakersfield that knows this way way
back they definitely know about that rap
video probably the only time you'll
catch me dancing as a DJ like I've had
people grow that's all you want dance
now no I don't dance so I you know after
that is just that was the last time
really probably I'm not a dancer like
that and I'll do that they used to put
me on stage to dance yeah but I for
money of course I had to get paid they
didn't used to put him on stage he
wanted to be on I was all about the bag
early on he looked like a tattoo from
Fantasy Island back in the day when he
was smaller so they they put him in a
he'd have like a tuxedo and do a dance
routine and all stuff so he was he was
always a ham for the stage and being in
front of everybody I was more like leave
me leave me alone not coming back here
I'll do my part to it
yeah but I'm more chill back back back
back stage type stuff you know yeah what
up Alex what's the deal you got Joe's
coming down yeah it will be over there
back again second week of December in
soccer ticket skeptical yeah that shows
people's jobs will find your show at
there's a couple places
- radio every morning download the -
radio app and tune into the city that's
the name of the child that's the name of
the radio station 69 am also you can
watch us on our twitch app but let me
get make it all easier follow us on
Instagram there's a link there you click
there and everything's there Instagram
at the Baker boys th e ba ka Bo Y Z or
when we're at my April Fool nineteen
nineties whenever we knew that switched
over here hey Rach can I was amazing we
were talking about that how that [ __ ] I
never forget it bro Kevin and being keep
calling you guys I don't know how to do
the mixtape
I don't know the road car didn't want
help they were getting death threats
they were getting death race opened up
k-rock in the morning and give it a beam
we're at par 106 yeah yeah take this
take this how long I'll start bro the
idea like that I don't even know who
came up with the idea I don't know if it
was Rick or that means asked us to do it
he asked would you mind switching
morning shows with k-rock what for you
know April Fool's will be like we're
down you know we're cool like we'll do
it you know we were open to it we'd like
some of the music they play anyway we
knew the music as well so they switch
they came to our show they tried to do
everything that we did so the roll call
the shout outs everything and they were
they were just like it was they were
like what are we doing like there we get
the threats yeah I'll do it
we're flustered they were getting
threats and stuff but we were cool okay
Raghu we had no problem we didn't get no
threats or nothing like that yeah they
were yeah I don't know I don't know but
I know people were like looking at their
dial like what the hell's going on my
stations why are they on here and what
you know the April Fool's you can be
right when you never there or another
station or saw him play Michael Jackson
it'll be the Michael Jackson station
there it was first back to regular yeah
yeah that was a great good radio jokes
back in when radio was something to
listen to it's like everything you do
was
based around a radio station whether it
was your mom or your you listening to
your radio that was your only media so
when that changed it was like what the
hell is going on here Christmas they
still do it on Christmas time like
they'll change the radio station and
play all Christmas new music music and
as a matter of fact the ratings shoot up
on some of the radio stations here in
Los and one of them I think is like
coast they switch all to Christmas and
legs April Fool's whereas which podcast
was joy cold odious mmm-hmm Oh Joey
talking about [ __ ]
we did another one in Miami that was
really big too
we did a
three chicken breasts we were giving
away chicken breasts to women we said
you'll first under three women to come
up you're gonna freak get a free pair of
breasts so we had a fake doctor and his
name was dr. Perdue and all this stuff
like that so we set it up we had all
these girls come up to the auditorium
line a hose line of them they were out
there was like the coldest day in
Florida that they dress for free breasts
by the way so they get up there and we
get the doctor up there to read
something and and we basically hi I'm
doctor Purdue Oh blah blah blah we want
to present you with your pair of breasts
and we opened the ice chest and it's
chicken breast a lot of the freaking
mind women started taking the breasts
strolling him all over they had to call
the cops cuz of you mother yeah all that
stuff but there was one smart girl she
took all the chicken she took all of it
we got so much crap for that from the
girls but yeah people still talk about
that one
what's another trade you get their bonus
say they got food damn well God had to
be the Billboard issue that's right the
billboards we had a we had people
picketing outside oh yeah because of our
was the what was the Latin wasn't even
at Mexico the Latin organization I
remember what it was it was probably
Alex Black was the name on the head of
the guy Alex something he was the head
of it he's probably still in booked that
puto so they basically picketed us there
was a TV stations that came out there
was write-ups about it it was James
almost came out I guess that's about
that everybody was like these guys are
or power 106 they were like power 106
days basically
so people were mad and then people like
I remember getting a call from somebody
one morning like I'm walking out a
chuck-e-cheese with my kid and you guys
are sitting there on some on the toilets
taking a crap eating pizza it was right
over a Chucky Cheese somewhere in LA so
yeah those got a lot of flack so those
are actually that's actually our now is
there anything goes yeah now that's our
logo for when we're on the air on - now
when I was
super controversial Oh totally
organization holy man yeah yeah they try
to stop us but they didn't like the fact
that we use Mexicans that we say to fat
Mexicans and there's no because there
are no [ __ ] Mexicans anywhere no we're
not angels they were they were saying oh
they're gonna stereotype us they do that
anyway exactly so I mean you know it was
a big big big fight about it to fat ass
Gabriel Iglesias man ain't no paso they
made him the face of water conservation
and water drinking and they go he's too
fast a dope asses off bunch of badasses
he's not good for water conservation
here they buy the little cheap water she
don't do soda come down it's crazy you
ever been El Paso everybody there has
like next like up there black rook slap
it was with brisket or something the
laser dart is tripe on a billboard rich
cookies yeah we came up with this idea
okay today yeah we came up with that
idea in the toilets so you know we
always try to do something different you
know
strike a chord yeah exactly you know
whether it's good or bad you know good
press bad press whatever as long as
people are talking about you and how did
I do a for ratings when that addictive
shoot him up more yeah well the
awareness made that make sure that
everybody knew that we were on the air
once they knew we were on the air and
they saw a billboard like that you have
to tune in you have to check it out and
they liked what they heard so we we beat
Howard Stern bkf I DS Rick Dees and
Kevin and boy yeah we're being all of
them el Cucuy yeah he was huge as all
the Latin stations they were huge we
surpassed all of those guys too fat
Mexicans from Bakersfield California
playing hip-hop records acting like
we're black
give us a bigger boy characters right
now you talking about the roll call
probably oh yeah are you gonna rap it
don't matter
just act like you can write yeah
already eating ready are you ready for
this one for the trouble two for the
time mr. Brokaw who's on that line
Philippe foof of Boyle Heights I came
here to do my parkas all right I wish
and that may be but where you come from
from White City
what's our forger Tori I'm Mike with
Riverside what's a full podcast up your
mother-fucking behind yeah we're
actually doing that we're doing a roll
call like ya'll star reunion with the
guys that really were the main guys that
always won on the show like they'd call
in they became like local celebrities in
their high schools and stuff so they're
actually coming to our show and we're
gonna do it live and we're gonna have a
like an open house one day and let
everybody come through this hangout so
yeah yeah yeah and do it live though
it'll be fun it'll be badass dude em so
what's up with you guys you guys are the
ones who got big boy in the radio to
know that yeah big boy used to hang out
with Nick V a lot so going you stand
yeah here's the bug the hell out of me
man I used to want to hang out and we
were introduced to him he was a
farsighted security guard and you know
he's a hip-hop head you know so he just
always used to call up all the time pick
me up and take me over to the hood to go
to strip clubs you know just hang out
take me gun shooting and [ __ ] like that
befriended me basically for the most
part and he was cool and he also had the
those phones the Chilika the clone
phones hold the brick the brick phone
button phones you know what
[Music]
yeah the brick phones that lasted
forever yeah anyway we used to hang out
a lot and he would call us up on Friday
night flavors and asked us to play
pistol grip pump oh yeah like Baker boys
I want you to hit that pistol grip pump
again it's going platinum in my suburban
cuz he had this big sound system in the
suburban
so I would put him on the radio I put
him on the air to request a song and
then we would play the song so that's
how it pretty much started and then
eventually after hanging out a little
bit longer him and fuzzy asked if they
could do a segment on the Friday night
favorite show so I was like cool we're
open
we know me and Eric have always been
open to talent to energy to people that
help us out and they're just it's just
how our energy is so we said yes he came
up he does a thing called this be it or
frisbee where they would play a song and
people would call in vote tell us what
they liked about it or didn't like about
it
there's beer to frisbee eight so that
was the beginning we brought him into
the station and then Rick Cummings was
actually at the station that night
hanging out for Friday night flavors
he's like who is that who'd you have on
the air right now
and I said a guy named big boys like I
would like to meet him I'm saying ooh
there it is there so big boy has a
career now because of that not only here
there's a lot of people I mean from Tito
to Amman to we open the doors for all
all those guys so a man how he got
discovered was we were having a contest
for Friday night flavors looking for a
new DJ I got about 40 mixtapes
in the mail and I went through every one
listened to every single one of them and
I was like this is the only guy that
gets it this is the only guy that knows
how to mix on beat in key on time he can
could scratch it we brought him up for
you know a live session on the air and
man I'm telling you his hands were like
this shaking he was nervous he was
extremely nervous but he's been there
like you know going on 20 years now you
know all those in that opened the door
for his brothers as well they started
grew Far East Movement and him being in
that power position where he can
actually play in break records you know
that fly like a g6 and all those big
records they have that opened the door
for all that so I mean from Tito to big
boy
- amen - hip-hop yeah so yeah yeah make
who lead there - no no we didn't we
didn't bring cool death she was on earth
she did her own thing yeah but her first
name was I'm cool and I told her she had
to change it that was your other name
I'm cool remember I know - what's it
like power 106 guys you guys got blocked
on social media whoa how did you know
about that you know yeah we don't we
don't really know why they lock this I
mean especially be the pioneers dawg
yeah I mean they they like to deny it
and that's fine and it's no big deal I
mean it's it's cool we're gonna do what
we do we're always pushing the envelope
we're always thinking of new stuff we're
always changing even though we we do
some of this the stuff we used to do
we're still always evolving we're with
with what's the music's going on now the
technology from the DJ side and and
looking for new talent as well opening
the doors like we've been we had a
search for a new co-host so we had like
three or like seven girls come in and
try out with us so we're we're trying
looking for new talent as well you know
so I'm not really sure
we've podcast doing podcasts yeah
hopefully they'll unblock us but it's
okay if they don't either we still got
love you know that's what it's about
yeah they can't take what we built away
for us like it's crazy after all these
years people still remember everything
we've done from the Sanford and Son song
like this new show we started people
were mad cuz nikoline playing the
Sanford and Son song bum bum bum yeah he
kept playing it but we wouldn't sing the
song so every is like this
it's amazing what effective get after
all these years people still remember
what we've done and that that just says
that we tour touched him in a certain uh
know Michael Jackson way not in a father
at a church way okay like we touched him
in a specific way that made them happy
and it brought them back to a great time
and that's that's amazing to us that's
that's worth doing what we do because we
were getting up at 4:00 in the morning
you know for them to do the show every
day and it seen text or a response like
that is that's what it's about
yeah and then it's like you guys in like
you don't mellow - in Cypress Hill were
like you know only Latinos put it on the
map oh no problem
chops out the LSO be shouts out to any
of our New York cats out there
Puerto Rico boutique was yeah York and
then Latin Latin field but yeah those
guys our forefathers [ __ ] yeah they were
get to be uncle jams army no no yeah
that was Katie but Katie was a huge
influence Yeah right
I mean Katie was the hub for us like it
that was like our nucleus to go to we
wanted to emulate them the best we could
remember other get up okay there used to
have a rap battle - OH
way back okay now see we're still in the
jams RV they have a rap battle okay they
would like somebody local
yeah never murder the rapper was you
know what [ __ ] that yeah we're good
rapper - what was your MC name I didn't
see the kid MC right now with a KB
folded over
yeah and merge before you had any
material things that $2 18 traversed
before Talent
ha ha so you're ready soon as you blow
up boom by this I'm on a bus to play
page Rijal Kim Kardashian when it's a
boy with a golden era of hip hop old
cheese in the radio thank you which is
classy yes we enjoyed our time the music
was incredible everything that came out
was dope oh no and if it wasn't dope we
didn't play it was very nice oh there
was times where we were doing a Friday
night flavors anniversary show and the
biggest record at the time was tag team
won't there it is tag team they tried to
put yeah they tried to put them on our
concert and we had outcast in Cypress
Hill and they wanted to put them and
there was like you can't do that he's
like but it's the big I don't care this
is what this is our show like you can't
like we fought tooth and nail to keep
them off of our show because we wanted
it to be pure and what we do and what
the show stood for and luckily he was
like you're right so we just you know
they got him out of the show they were
trying to book some commercial type acts
in the show like no there was another
time with this another situation another
concert and we did not want the Mac of
the year wasn't thinking drew down and
we did not want drew down to be on the
show because with the same argument now
he's not blah blah blah and then drew
down Mac of the year became one of the
biggest record and we're and we turned
them and were like yo he can come on now
[ __ ] right the house will move right
but yeah I remember that for sure
protecting back you huge yeah
so big it's still play and then people
love it it's a wedding song you can play
it weddings Bar Mitzvahs everywhere I'm
becoming a whole new man wait somebody
said we touched him you paid those guys
off you know I want to shout out useless
man who helped set this up so shut up
ethos that dudes a writer die for us man
so he's out there hustling and stuff so
shout out to him and thank you guys for
having me through your name out there
when we made Lisa Lisa in the cult jam
oh she's a friend of ours no in New York
yeah that's a Romanesque the funny
latina okay well you always call
Romanesque he called himself yeah that's
why we call him Romanesque I think his
name is Roman Roman swatters Romanus
warrants were so full Baker boy
freestyle makes oh yeah we played
everything Lopes Wario yeah you put a
couple albums out yeah Baker boy stop in
quick mix people will challenge each
other right and then they'll be a winner
right the bro call the roll call that's
right yeah they used to call up at 6:00
in the morning before they go to school
battle and then wait for us to get the
voters we'd have people call in who do
you vote for who do you vote for a Hugo
for so so crazy a from Santana and then
we would pick the winner and that winner
would go off on his day or her day and B
a G at school and those people used to
continue to win and over and over don't
become like champs it would win like ten
night days in a row little stars man for
sure was so foolish it was your
Instagram Rodrigo Torres jr. I
Felipe Esparza comedian you wanna play
me at Madrid man yeah I said what's a
full pod I'm ready to kick your ass
what's up Becket boys in the house right
yeah mr. Rory tattoos oh yeah yeah yeah
at the Baker boys th e ba baby oh I see
before you leave it's out now yeah yeah
I seen that it's a little guy from Game
of Thrones
Peter Dinklage I think so too
Brad Williams Portugal special and the
degenerate also Jodie especially the
generators to the P Jay said Oakridge ok
ok big day ok I run into them at the
airport man bill burr Pardo Jimmy Pardo
Jimmy Pardo Brad Williams and karaoke
Steven a doe authorized that's the way
to do it because you have entourage
attracts attention but we were standing
by the window holy world I just a fat
guy a little person a person that could
be a little person jimmy pardo right
person shows up bill burr
there's a little bit of rest or little
red ants what so full of dingo toys in
their mouth there when does beat down
bro
what's up fool part cast shut up -
together chopped on stage and everybody
look at the show man what's up fool
thank you very much for downloading our
podcast every week I know you got other
things to do but damn other people in a
bigger bear podcast yeah and Alex the
large hear the podcast - no right one
day we're all gonna be one podcast
together what so boo Yemen George Perez
stories
that's right [ __ ] don't forget
about us